ici à nice on est vraiment sans espoir
de retrouver albert spaggiari et
pourtant le dispositif policier mis en
place est vraiment exceptionnel un
contrôleur général monsieur guy denis un
responsable de l'inspection générale des
services monsieur calais tous deux venus
directement de paris sur ans du ministre
intérieur michel poniatowski mille
policiers de nice et des environs traque
depuis hier après-midi le cerveau du
casse de la société générale
rien n'est négligé l'aéroport bien sûr
mais aussi les routes en direction de
l'italie
le bord de mer où chaque embarcation et
vérifier les policiers ne cachent pas
leur mécontentement après le mal qu'ils
ont eu à arrêter albert spaggiari
ils ne comprennent pas qu'ils aient pu
s'évader avec autant de facilité
une évasion qui il faut bien le dire
amusé les niçois qui comparent serait
thierry arsène lupin c'est hier après
midi alors qu'il était dans les bureaux
du juge d'instruction que spaggiari
ancien parachutiste a brusquement
effectué un saut de 7 mètres sur le toit
de cette voiture
alors on a une fraction de seconde j'ai
assisté à cette marche en plastique soit
jarry a fait demi tour sur lui même il a
mis la main sur la craie bonne qui a
ouvert la fenêtre il se trouve est fermé
il a enjambé celle-ci pareil le
directement la mène il enjambe et le la
fête et s'est jeté dans le vide et tout
ceci a demandé quelques dixièmes de
seconde
et puis à la fenêtre nous avons vu une
moto qui s'enfuyait avec spaggiari à
l'arrière s'est tourné vers nous
apparemment indemne avec un sourire et
en faisant croire de la depuis spa jerry
reste introuvable
certains disent qu'il se terre chez des
amis dans la région de nice d'autres
affirment qu'il a réussi à passer en
italie
ce dont on est sûr c'est que cet ancien
combattant d'indochine ancien os
cambrioleurs au grand coeur par idéal
politique prétend qu'il reste toujours
en possession de 2 milliards d'anciens
francs que sa femme a également disparu
et qu'il sera très difficile de recours
et albert spaggiari